hey guys I'm Ryan right so today I'm
gonna be checking out the first look for
a super girl everyone's asking me to
look at this I want to establish
something up front
I don't know jack-shit about Supergirl
and what makes her so different
I think she's call Elle's cousin that's
what I mean I don't really know much oh
sorry I got a lot of energy right now my
name is Kara zor-el 24 years ago my
planet was in peril
my cousin kal-el was sent to a planet
called Earth you may know his story yeah
but you don't know mine
I'm earth you will to extraordinary
things until now that's when I'll be
home
I Love You Carla
[Music]
Sorry Sorry
I'm calling about the Correspondents
Dinner I need to make sure miss grant
doesn't end up next to Bill O'Reilly
again hey um I was wondering if maybe
you want to I don't know go see a movie
tonight
I can't I'm sorry I have a date
Hey hmm fine dating is fine she's here
how do you do that the only reason I
bought this building was because it had
a private elevator that way I don't have
to get soaked in cheap cologne every
morning getting to my office find out
who used it have them reprimanded or
bathed I don't care which you're
watching hot Oh that'll be new and
different hello I've seen this picture
they won a Pulitzer yeah only cause it
was the first real shot of a little
secret you actually posed with that
guess she likes me oh my god you're
Jimmy Olsen at the top of her broom the
day we bought it James Olsen he's black
- me gosh hi I am Cara Wow
I have a conference in Geneva and I need
to be on a plane in two hours
I'm a blind date and a half an hour and
I need you to help me pick out what to
wear why do you do this - because I'm
your sister and you love me feel like
I'm not living up to my potential
seems like my exact sign of coffee you
always want it to be normal this is what
normal looks like I'm not normal I can
lift a bus stop a bullet
Alex I could fly least I think I can by
2:37 bound for Geneva is circling the
city after engine failure did he say
Geneva
[Music]
oh [ __ ] uh sorry dick
[Music]
we just lost another engine
going down brace for impact
Oh
[Music]
who is the mystery flying woman who
saved the plane you're out there now
Cara everyone will know about you and
you can't take that back
I don't want to media magnate cat grant
up national city's new female hero
Supergirl
we can't name her that we didn't
shouldn't you be called super woman what
do you think is so bad about girl I'm a
girl and your boss and powerful and rich
and hot and smart so if you perceive
Supergirl is anything less than
excellent isn't the real problem you
darah I'm going to tell you something
about me that for most of my life I've
run from it but last night I embraced
Who I am and I don't want to stop oh my
god you're a lesbian
Oh Karl that's why you're not into me
this is this is this is great news are
you guys yeah [ __ ] loser
the woman who saved the play okay right
what are you doing Hey
[Music]
Hey that look pretty cool I'm not flying
around saving people in this thing
where's my cape
keeps your laying tell you cousin I said
so actually never never do that hmm
so to be a superhero you need a crime
there's a car chase on the 112 freeway I
could do a car chase
Cape aids with aerodynamics I should
have thought of that are you sure you're
bulletproof hope so
forgetting all marking positive so much
sturdier and uh this one has the s for
super just like a cousin it's not nests
it's my family's coat of arms you look
good
welcome to the Department of
extra-normal operations the EEO monitors
and protects Earth from extraterrestrial
presence
these beings some of them are powers
from your darkest nightmares I can help
you stop him
I don't trust aliens you want to help go
back to getting someone's coffee kara
it's me I know what you're thinking but
the world needs you to fly and so do i
so what do we do now
first things first you need to change
this ism
have you traveled 2,000 light-years just
to be an assistant people of this city
will dark
have to let me stop it make sure you
[Music]
[Music]
my cousin wanted me to do this how did
he just tell me because he wanted you to
choose it for yourself
same way he did hear from him
[Music]
it's the blanket he was wrapped in when
he was a baby
apparently this Cape won't shred thank
you now don't you have a city to protect
you know up open oi I'm like very
weirdly compelled right now the a part
of me is like yeah okay um this is a
total show meant for a female
demographic but fanboys will watch it
because you know Supergirl is pretty
popular amongst fanboys so it's kind of
smart marketing because you know like
comic books movies don't really give
that much attention to the females so
now they're really putting a female
front and center they're doing the whole
storyline like outside of her being
Supergirl it's very much like The Devil
Wears Prada or some [ __ ] it's like a
network girlie show and I don't know the
exact terminology for it but it's
Supergirl and it works that's the other
thing it's like although that's not my
kind of show that I would probably just
watch in the background or if I'm
hanging out with someone they're
watching it like I'll probably like
force myself to just try to enjoy it
watching this I was like you know what
sometimes in those movies that have that
I do enjoy it I did enjoy the Devil
Wears Prada
so that might actually be really
interesting stuff I feel like I would
not be interested in it enough to
actually continue this series but then
when she was Supergirl it was really
cool like it did make me this you know
all those like cheesy and corny and
girly I felt by the end of the trailer
like I'm rooting for this chick not just
because she's hot I mean that's probably
the number one reason why I'm rooting
for her but man [ __ ] when she got in to
Supergirl outfits holy [ __ ] I got to
make my girlfriend wear
that my girlfriend's working out so much
right now
but this girl I don't know who the
actress is but no she was she was
[ __ ] sexy and I like how her
personality as I don't know the name of
who she's pretending to be a human being
as I like her personality cuz it does
seem like oh yeah you wouldn't expect
this girl to be her I know you could say
the same thing about Clark Kent but like
what Clark Kent like Clark Kent was
still like buff you just had glasses and
his hair was done a little different her
yeah she has glasses her hair is done
different but she's also like doesn't
look like she's some really buff chick
she has a really good body though like
woah she is so [ __ ] hot that's
something I didn't even think that was
gonna be a cadet like I imagine that
when you're putting together Supergirl
that people are like we want to make
sure that whoever Supergirl is that
she's [ __ ] sexy right
I'm sure that's what the producers are
thinking and they [ __ ] did it like
whoa illiterate my heart started beating
how odd she was I do appreciate - how
they're not like trying to completely
just take Superman out of this world
like they're greatly acknowledging that
yes
Superman is a part of this universe cuz
I don't like it when yet like okay an
example that sort of applies the
Catwoman movie with Halle Berry it's
like just ignore the fact that Catwoman
is really from the Batman world like now
they're really showing us a yes
Supergirl is the cousin of callout
Superman still exists in this world
Jimmy I don't know in the comics if he's
black or not but he was black in this
and I wasn't expecting that not a bad
thing at all I like black guys you could
always count on most thing black guys to
also have an eight back don't forget
that ladies and gay guys yeah so like
I'm compelled to check it out because I
want to see her kick ass a Supergirl and
I found myself like really rooting for
her feeling like yeah you know she's
denying who she is and now she wants to
embrace who she is and I I am a sucker
for stories like that and it looks
pretty apparent that the story is not
going to beat her as Supergirl like most
of the time that I feel like there's
going to be a lot of the drama outside
of her being Supergirl that drama does
seem strongly
targeted towards a female audience it's
like I don't have a problem with that
but is that something that will
constantly keep me coming back I'm not
sure I'm not saying that stuff is bad
I'm just saying it's not really for me
but yeah I'm gonna give it a chance man
I don't know what this is like linking
to the other DC shows of the DC movies I
don't know anything about this but I do
want to check it out because she looks
like she's [ __ ] hot as hell and she's
kicking ass a Supergirl and she makes
Supergirl look like a really cool
superhero because I have an investment
and who she is as a person
prior to her exposing her powers and
that's usually where a lot of these
shows kind of go wrong for me especially
just what trailers like I'll be like
when are they gonna be flash when are
they gonna do this and I found myself
like I like this girl and when she
becomes super good I'm like oh yeah then
there's that part which look badass
rating time I will check Supergirl out
[Music]
anyway guys thanks for tuning in if
you're new to the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects you give
all us on Facebook Instagram and Twitter
where if we get enough followers we can
potentially get product placement and
less work for me no benefit for you for
example um camera bags camera bags are
great you never know when you want a
vlog when you want to take a picture of
something you never know when you're
going to be walking through a
neighborhood and then a couple having
sex or several people having sex have
left their windows open use that camera